you're not going to change your entire
business to make something sound
different but you can make it look
different I call it magic because it's
an acronym m is a magnetic reason why
it's Black Friday and everyone expects
that the second is the Avatar you want
to say it's available for a local market
or for somebody of a certain age group G
is for goal what's the ultimate outcome
you want the person to experience the I
is for a time interval and then C is
something that I call the container work
if I wanted to do something around
stress I might say busy moms so we got
our Avatar goal is relaxation holidays
is my reason why 30 days and then this
would be getaway so just like that we
can create our busy mom's 30-day
relaxation getaway for the holidays boom